die Ukraine sieht sich eigentlich schon
im dritten Weltkrieg das sagen
sieht sich eigentlich schon mittendrin
in diesem Krieg und wenn es nach der
Ukraine gehen würde dann würden deutsche
Soldaten an der Befreiung am Dom was
mitkämpfen die NATO in den die direkt
involviert werden das wäre die Ukraine
pur sozusagen und wir haben andere
Interessen weil wir abwägen müssen
zwischen der Unterstützung der Ukraine
wir sind immer wir Deutschland wir sind
wir Deutsche oder wir politischer Westen
wir wollen nicht das ist das erklärte
Ziel der Amerikaner der NATO der
deutschen der Franzosen aller nicht in
einen Krieg mit Russland geraten und das
ist schwer zu balancieren die Ukraine
unterstützen aber wollen nicht in einen
Krieg mit Russland geraten und aus dem
Grund beteiligen wir uns ja auch nicht
mit eigene natursoldaten das heißt im
Prinzip lassen wir doch die Ukraine in
einer Art Stellvertreter Krieg für uns
für unsere Rhetorik dort kämpfen
[Musik]